keine sonderrechte für geimpfte die
korona regeln sollen weiter ohne
ausnahme für alle gelten empfiehlt der
ethikrat 150 euro pro kind die regierung
beschließt corona hilfen für familien
und auch für empfänger von
grundsicherung zu wenig kritisiert die
opposition
wir haben fehler gemacht erstmals gibt
der kölner kardinal woelki zu bei der
aufarbeitung von missbrauchsfällen sei
einiges schief gelaufen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und willkommen schön
dass sie dabei sind wie auch norbert
lehmann für den sport ein stück von mir
wenn es um die großen fragen des lebens
geht dann sind in deutschland die
wissenschaftler des ethikrats dran so
auch heute
zwar sind erst die wenigsten hierzulande
gegen korona geimpft gerade mal zwei von
82 millionen
trotzdem wird schon heftig diskutiert
sollten geimpfte zurück in ihr normales
leben dürfen also ohne corona
einschränkungen ins konzert kino oder
restaurant
der deutsche ethikrat sagt nein vor
allem solange noch unklar ist wie sehr
geimpfte doch noch ansteckend sein
können
liebe mit der zeit die regeln für alle
lockern so die empfehlung
patricia wiedemeier keine guten
nachrichten für geimpfte die abstands
und hygieneregeln noch länger
einzuhalten das sei jedem zuzumuten so
der ethikrat dieses gremium hat es zwar
nicht zu entscheiden aber gibt
empfehlungen für die politik und die
botschaft heute ist klar keine
sonderregelungen zum gegenwärtigen
zeitpunkt sollte aufgrund der noch nicht
verlässlich abschätzbaren infektiosität
eine individuelle rücknahme staatlicher
freiheitsbeschränkungen für geimpfte
personen nicht erfolgen so lange noch
nicht alle die chance hatten sich impfen
zu lassen würden viele besondere rechte
für geimpfte als ungerecht empfinden
solange also nicht geklärt ist ob von
geimpften menschen eine gefahr ausgeht
ob sie noch ansteckend sind soll es
keine lockerungen
ebenso der ethik art erst wenn deutlich
mehr menschen als bisher geimpft sind
dann könne gelockert werden
schnellstmöglich sollen vor allem die
maßnahmen in alten- und pflegeheim
aufgehoben werden wird empfehlen deshalb
mit nachdruck dass diese besonderen
kontakt beschränkungen in pflege
senioren behinderten und
hospizeinrichtungen mit dem
fortschreiten des impfprogramms
schnellstmöglich aufgehoben würden die
opposition will die beschränkung der
freiheitsrechte so früh wie möglich
aufheben stattdessen risikogruppen
besser schützen
wir befürchten eine spaltung der
gesellschaft in geimpft und nicht die
impfte eine art zweiklassengesellschaft
wo man sagt okay wer geimpft ist darf
schon wieder alles der rest darf nichts
wir lehnen das ab wir glauben dass
grundrechte jedem bürger zu stehen und
dass die auch jetzt wieder alles zu
stehen müssen uns ist besonders wichtig
dass wenn dieser nachweis erbracht es
wir nicht noch drei monate diskutieren
sondern spätestens heute müsste jedem
klar sein wenn der nachweis erbracht ist
dass geimpfte andere menschen nicht
anstecken können dann müssen sie ihre
freiheitsrechte zurück bekommen auch
private anbieter wie zum beispiel
konzertveranstalter künftig ihre
dienstleistungen nur geimpften personen
zugänglich machen dürfen ja so der
ethikrat grundsätzlich gelte in der
wirtschaft vertragsfreiheit ausgenommen
ist die grundversorgung sonderrechte für
geimpfte auch bei zdf heute live gleich
um halb acht wird das thema diskutiert
unter anderem mit der vorsitzenden des
ethikrats alina books und dem rapper
smudo beiden können sie auch ihre fragen
stellen auf zdf heute.de und in ungarn
wie gut schützt die impfung
vielversprechende antworten kommen aus
israel
das land impft im rekordtempo seine
bevölkerung mit dem impfstoff von
biontech weise und sammelt dabei
massenweise daten die erste impfdosis
hat dort inzwischen rund jeder dritte
erhalten bei den über 60 jährigen liegt
die impfquote bei 85 prozent mehr von
michael beverungen
noch sind die intensivstationen in
israel überlastet aber seit ein paar
tagen gibt es einen neuen trend die zahl
der älteren patienten mit schweren ko
witt 19 symptomen nimmt massiv ab dabei
ist 60 plus die risikogruppe mit
schweren verläufen ihre solar ist eine
der ganz wenigen patienten die trotz
zwei impfungen positiv auf 19 getestet
wurden
obwohl 66 jahre alt zeigt sie keine
krankheitszeichen
ich hatte keinerlei symptome auch jetzt
nicht ich hätte ohne den test überhaupt
nicht daran gedacht
es war eine totale überraschung für mich
anna egger so hart von der makkabi
krankenkasse kann das empirisch
bestätigen die kasse erfasst alle daten
ihrer 25 millionen versicherten digital
auch jeden corona test das ergebnis
einer studie könnte klarer kaum sein
eine woche nach der zweiten impfung sind
fast 100 prozent immun
wir hatten insgesamt nur 66 patienten
die nach der zweiten dosis erkrankten
von wie vielen in der studie von 250.000
patienten nur 66 erkrankte überhaupt und
die haben wir nach symptomen gefragt
sehr sehr leicht in lohr wie
kopfschmerzen schwäche müdigkeit aber
überhaupt niemand mit fieber und noch
etwas macht mut experten glauben dass
der bayern tag wirkstoff in israel wie
der von astrazeneca weitgehend
verhindert dass auch bereits geimpfte
trotzdem noch andere anstecken könnten
ich denke wir werden hier etwas
ähnliches sehen wir sind noch etwas
davon entfernt die masken in der
öffentlichkeit abzunehmen aber es ist
viel weniger ansteckend viel weniger
auch das kabinett sieht wo licht am ende
des tunnels und berät bereits heute über
eine lockerung des lotter uns nächste
woche
schauen wir auf die aktuellen zahlen in
deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet 14.200 elf neue infektionen
innerhalb von 24 stunden das sind 3342
weniger als vergangenen donnerstag 786
menschen sind in verbindung mit dem
virus gestorben
die sieben tage inzidenz die zahl der
ansteckungen pro 100.000 einwohner
binnen einer woche sinkt kontinuierlich
und liegt inzwischen bei 80,7 um die
korona krise abzufedern hat der
koalitionsausschuss gestern abend
weitere milliardenhilfen beschlossen die
union setzte ihre vorschläge für die
wirtschaft durch die spd ihre für
familien und geringverdiener an seinem
stern fast das wichtigste zusammen viele
neue milliarden sollen helfen gegen die
folgen des virus stillstands familien
bekommen wie schon im vergangenen jahr
einen so genannten kinderbonus einmalig
150 euro pro kind letztes mal waren es
300 euro
eine corona sonderzahlung soll es auch
geben für die die besonders wenig haben
empfänger der grundsicherung bekommen
ebenfalls 150 euro so der beschluss in
dem auch weitere hilfen für unternehmen
vorgesehen sind und zwar beim thema
steuern die verluste in den pandemie
zeiten können künftig noch stärker mit
den gewinnen aus den vorjahren
verrechnet werden von gewinnen weit
entfernt die gastronomie geschlossen
seit vielen wochen der verminderte
mehrwertsteuersatz von sieben prozent
für speisen in restaurants soll deshalb
länger gelten bis ende 2022 mehr hilfe
auch für kunst und kultur die zahlungen
hier sollen verdoppelt werden auf zwei
milliarden euro unterstützung etwa für
museen theater oder kinos die wegen
corona schon so lange geschlossen sind
mögliche hilfen oder der berühmte
tropfen auf den heißen stein armen
familien und geringverdienern reiche das
beschlossene nicht kritisierte deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund ähnlich der
paritätische wohlfahrtsverband die
regierung habe die not der armen monate
lang ignoriert und
sie nun mit 150 euro ab auch
wirtschaftsverbände hatten sich mehr
erhofft der autoverband vga etwa nannte
den umfang der hilfen ernüchternd in der
pandemie wachsen auch
verschwörungstheorien und hassreden herr
experten warnen vor einer zunehmenden
radikalisierung im internet aber auch
ganz offen auf der straße extremisten
nutzen ganz bewusst aus dass viele
momentan sehr viel zeit am computer
verbringen elisabeth schmidt auf
plattformen wie steam oder twitch
tauschen sich gamer eigentlich über
computerspiele aus immer öfter stoßen
sie dabei auf eindeutig rechtsextreme
parolen vor allem jugendliche werden in
foren vermeintlich harmlos zu
patriotischen isport turnieren
eingeladen
gaming ist durch corona einfach eine
viel größere austausch ort geworden als
er vorher schon war und auch
rechtsextreme nutzen das halt einfach
vermerk man sieht es einfach die sind
aktive sie machen mehr angebote sie
machen der veranstaltungen immer mehr
menschen radikalisieren sich im internet
warnen sicherheitsbehörden bundesweit
die korona krise einen nährboden für
demokratiefeindliches gedankengut das
sind gute mischung das ist aber viel aus
der rechten szene was wir beobachten
auch aus der rechtsextremen szene
dann sind es natürlich so diese
sogenannten leugner die korona leugner
und das stößt dann eben auf menschen die
zugegebenermaßen berechtigt ja auch
verunsichert sind
hass und hetze entladen sich zunehmend
auch auf der straße das
bundesinnenministerium warnt vor einer
sogwirkung und einem erhöhten
eskalationspotenzial bei anti corona
demonstrationen das problem
radikale gruppen mit antisemitischer und
rechtsextremer gesinnung mischen sich
unter die demonstranten
das ist auch eine chance auf der
rechtsextreme szene heraus die sagt
gehen wir können jetzt sagen zu menschen
vordringen die eigentlich sonst keine
berührungspunkte mit uns haben und dann
sind das glaube ich sagen wenn man sich
das bild so anguckt so ein bisschen er
nicht die ganz jungen menschen sondern
vielleicht auch mittlere und ein höheres
alter die hier quasi sichtbar sind und
sich radikalisieren ob auf der straße
oder im internet streetworker versuchen
rechten parolen und
verschwörungstheorien fakten
entgegenzusetzen
präventionsarbeit scheint wichtiger denn
je us-präsident beiden macht nach und
nach die maßnahmen seines vorgängers
rückgängig donald trump wollte 12.000
amerikanischen soldaten aus deutschland
abziehen
diese pläne hat beiden jetzt erstmal
gestoppt trumps partei die republikaner
müssen sich nach seiner wahlniederlage
neu sortieren die frage ist wie hat der
schnitt sein soll
beispielhaft dafür steht sie marjorie
taylor green
sie vertritt immer wieder rassistische
ansichten und zählt zu den anhängern der
grünen verschwörungstheorien trump lobte
sie als künftigen star der republikaner
zur stunde geht es im kongress um ihre
politische zukunft aus washington peter
jäger stopp bis di fordert marie taylor
green immer wieder und ist überzeugt
donald trump habe die wahl nur durch
betrug verloren
drinnen kämpft die
verschwörungstheoretiker hin zur stunde
um ihre politische zukunft taylor greens
rauswurf aus mehreren ausschüssen droht
zuvor hatte der fraktionschef der
republikaner noch für die abgeordnete
getrommelt sie hat gesagt dass sie
falsch gelegen hat und sie hat das auch
auf mehreren wegen klar gemacht nichts
von all dem was sie einmal gesagt hat
lag in ihrer zeit als kongressmitglied
und die wähler die haben entschieden
dass sie hierher kommen sollte erst seit
kurzem sitzt taylor green für georgia im
repräsentantenhaus
ein kongress neuling der die grand old
party in ein politisches dilemma stürzt
die partei streitet über unterstützung
oder ablehnung einer abgeordneten die
glühende trump anhängerin ist und offen
die verschwörungs bewegungen unterstützt
in einem video etwa bedrängte sie einen
überlebenden des schulmassakers von
parkland behauptete die schießerei mit
17 toten sei inszeniert gewesen
wir haben ein glaubwürdigkeitsproblem
wir tragen die last aus zehn wochen von
der desinformation und allen möglichen
verschwörungstheorien
wenn wir weiter solche leute wählen die
solche ansätze verfolgen werden wir als
republikaner weiter verlieren
für den richtungsstreit der republikaner
steht auch sie liz cheney wiederum hatte
für die amtsenthebung von donald trump
gestimmt der rechte flügel wollte sie
loswerden
seit einer fraktionssitzung gestern ist
klar sie darf ihr spitzenamt behalten
die republikaner suchen ihre zukunft in
der post trump er vier tage nach dem
militärputsch in myanmar wächst der
widerstand gegen den staatsstreich
dutzende gewählte abgeordnete haben sich
symbolisch zu einer sitzung des
parlaments getroffen
in den strassen schlagen menschen aus
protest gegen den putsch auf blech köpfe
sie fordern dass die regierung und
friedensnobelpreisträgerin aung san suu
kyi wieder eingesetzt wird
die militärregierung hat facebook
gesperrt der zivile widerstand wird
wesentlich über das netzwerk organisiert
noch eine nachricht aus der wirtschaft
positive schlagzeilen warum bei der
deutschen bank in den vergangenen jahren
eher rar
jetzt meldet der konzern trotz der
korona krise einen deutlichen
jahresgewinn und zwar zum ersten mal
seit 2014-2020 betrug der überschuss 624
millionen euro nach abzug der
zinszahlungen entfällt auf die aktionäre
des dax konzerns ein gewinn von 113
millionen euro maßgeblich für die
schwarzen zahlen war laut angaben des
konzern vor allem das investmentgeschäft
versuchter mord sprengstoffanschläge
sachbeschädigungen das und mehr soll auf
das konto der rechts terroristischen
gruppe freital gehen in einen von
mehreren prozessen
in dresden mitglieder und unterstützer
der gruppe verurteilt einer der
angeklagten war nach überzeugung der
richter an mindestens zwei anschlägen
beteiligt er muss für zweieinhalb jahre
ins gefängnis gegen drei weitere
unterstützer wurden bewährungsstrafen
verhängt im erzbistum köln hat es schon
länger kardinal woelki wird vorgeworfen
er unterdrückte erkenntnisse zu
sexuellem missbrauch im bistum selbst
der vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz bätzing sprach heute
von schlechtem krisenmanagement und
stockender aufarbeitung viele gläubiger
in köln ziehen längst ihre eigenen
konsequenzen
dorthe farbe berichtet kölns
kirchenaustritt stelle ist überlastet
1000 neue termine waren gerade nach
einem tag weg sabine baron hatte ihren
termin schon vorher ergattert jetzt
tritt sie auch kardinal woelki hält ein
gutachten zur aufarbeitung der
sexualisierten gewalt im erzbistum köln
unter verschluss auch er persönlich
steht unter vertuschungs verdacht dass
weist er zurück
der unmut in köln er ist groß und
beispiellos selbst führende geistliche
wie kölns stadtdekan äußern jetzt offen
kritik vor den namen der
verantwortlichen und konsequenzen im
augenblick erlebe ich leider gottes bei
vielen menschen dass sie sagen will den
wirklich aufgeklärt werden ist da nicht
irgendwo etwas das man doch vertuscht
die bistumsleitung bittet weiter um
geduld mitte märz soll alles auf den
tisch mit einem neuen zweiten gutachten
das erste gutachten so sagen uns
expertin weist viele mängel auf so dass
die erwartung der öffentlichkeit dadurch
gar nicht gedeckt werden können
hinzu kommt dass wir durch eine
veröffentlichung des ersten gutachtens
jetzt bestehendes recht brechen würden
der vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz fordert heute alle
untersuchungsergebnisse müssten
offengelegt verantwortung übernommen
werden
auch ein rücktritt könne kein tabu sein
er bedauere die stockende aufarbeitung
in köln
das eine ist die aufarbeitung wie sie
geplant ist
das andere ist das krisen management und
da muss man einfach sagen von außen da
sind doch fehler gemacht worden
kardinal will kommt heute auch fehler
ein
und er verstehe die ungeduld zur
aufklärung des missbrauchs sagt
erweitert nichts zur hochwasserlage in
deutschland die bleibt angespannt denn
an vielen flüssen steigen die
pegelstände weiter an wie hier am rhein
rund um düsseldorf promenaden und
straßen sind überflutet die schifffahrt
ist hier nur noch eingeschränkt möglich
köln hat sie bereits ganz eingestellt
auch im süden deutschlands haben die
menschen weiter mit überschwemmungen zu
kämpfen
entspannen soll sich die lage erst in
der kommenden woche
und jetzt der sport norbert beim dfb
pokal hat wieder ein kleiner einen
großen rausgeworfen eben genau im
achtelfinale erst war es ja viertligist
rot-weiss essen der die leverkusener
rausgeworfen hat dann gestern abend ein
zweitligist
die kölner jahn regensburg machte es
besonders spannend erst verlängerung das
elfmeterschießen
am ende stand es 6 zu 5 für die
oberpfälzer dabei hatte köln schon in
der regulären spielzeit die chance zum
sieg doch regensburgs torhüter meyer
nils gegen dennis das 2 2 unentschieden
fest ich habe schon gesagt meine jungs
vorm spiel wir wollen endlich mal
geschichte schreiben wir sind hier um zu
gewinnen spiele zu gewinnen auch im
elfmeterschießen hatten die kölner den
sieg auf dem fuß doch der spanier mehr
re vergab den strafstoß zum möglichen
erfolg
als kurz darauf auch jannis ohren rechts
vorbei zielte war der weg frei für max
gesucht stoff und vier jahren regensburg
dass damit zum ersten mal das dfb pokal
viertelfinale erreicht das achtelfinal
hinspiel in der champions league
zwischen leipzig und liverpool am 16
februar kann nicht stattfinden
die bundespolizei hat die einreise der
englischen fußballer wegen corona
abgelehnt heute in einem jahr statt die
olympischen winterspiele in peking
die pandemie ist das eine thema das die
austragung erschweren könnte das andere
die menschenrechtslage in china das ioc
steht unter druck forderungen nach einem
internationalen boykott der winterspiele
2022 werden laut von einem bündnis von
180 menschenrechtsgruppen und
minderheitenvertreter das ioc muss sich
den vorwurf stellen sich nicht an die
eigenen vergaberegeln zu halten und dem
wissen um menschenrechtsverletzungen die
spiele an peking vergeben zu haben die
spiele finden in einem land statt das
die menschenrechte systematisch mit
füßen tritt
bereits jetzt steht peking 20 22 unter
einem ungünstigen vorzeichen
winterspiele in einer stadt der
sommerspiele 150 kilometer nordwestlich
von peking ist aus dem nichts ein
skigebiet entstanden
dabei hat wintersport keine tradition in
china in münchen 2018 gab es gerade mal
eine goldmedaille für einen chinesen
ski rennläufer thomas dreesen ist nach
seiner hüft op zurück auf der piste beim
training für die weltcup abfahrt in
garmisch partenkirchen landete er zwar
nur auf platz 41 fuhr nach eigenen
angaben ohne schmerzen ist morgen aber
lediglich als vorläufer dabei voll dabei
sind wir morgen die abfahrt in garmisch
live ab 11.15 bei uns immer gut zu
wissen
danke bitte das wetter bringt morgen 9
regen die details hat gleich ist charlie
foto v10 ist zeit fürs heute schon mal
mit christian sievers danke für ihr
interesse
machen sie sich noch einen schönen abend
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen auch
wieder sehen
ein schöner name und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter seit gut einer woche hält
sich nun die kaltluft im norden
deutschlands und immer wieder rennen die
warmen luftmassen dagegen an und das ist
die vorhersage bis zum wochenende es
geht also weiter so und am wochenende
stellt sich eine unwetter situation im
norden deutschlands ein hier kommt es zu
ergiebigen schneefällen zu schauen wir
uns mal genauer an kann es 20 bis 40
zentimeter in diesem schraffierten
bereich geben und kräftiger ostwind also
es wird eher ein schneesturm und
gefrierender regen gibt es ist auch
dabei südlich davon und spiegelglatte
straßen
dass also die vorhersage bis zum
wochenende schauen wir mal die kommende
nacht und da kommt er im südwesten regen
auf sonst ist es überwiegend trocken nur
im westen kann es auch etwas tröpfeln
einige schneeflocken können dabei sein
bei minus sechs grad im nordosten und 7
grad im südwesten
bonn kommt der regen allmählich bis zum
mitte voran sonst nach osten ist es eher
trocken und das bei temperaturen von
minus 1 grad an der ostsee bis 14 grad
im südwesten deutschlands die kommenden
tage samstag hatten wir eben gesehen
hier kommt schnee auf der sich
allmählich ausweitet -2 bis 13 grad
untertags steht der schneesturm an damit
ein schöner abend